[Alexandra] Are you sure
he's gonna be here?
[giggles]
As long as there's a worthy competition…
He'll never miss a race.
Just make sure you don't forget our deal.
[giggles]
Don't worry about us.
Just keep your eye on the road.
And make sure to have our prize
at the finish line.
[engine roars]
[brakes squeak]
Eh, you up for a race?
It depends.
You up for a challenge?
Haven't turned one down yet.
Winner gets a trophy.
[snickers]
Haven't heard that in a while.
You'll have to win first.
[engine revs]
Ready, set…
[tires screech]
[engines roaring]
[upbeat music]
[clanks]
[engines revving]
[clicking]
[engines roaring]
[high-pitched humming]
[panting]
[tense music]
[galloping]
Anytime you're ready, girls.
Then you better hold on to your hairdo.
'Cause once we go,
there's no turning back.
Whoo-hoo-hoo!
Now!
[engine roars]
-Yeah!
[cheering]
[hooves clopping]